die kanzlerin selbst hatte ein
versprechen gegeben wir helfen den orts
kräften in afghanistan jetzt aber jetzt
gibt es neue zahlen die belegen so
vielen orts- kräften helfen wir
überhaupt gar nicht der patrizia wir
haben gerade eben unser kollege philipp
iad of neue zahlen rein bekommen darüber
wer ist eigentlich gerettet worden ihr
habt es hier auch schon in kürze
motiviert 3,6 prozent der geretteten aus
afghanistan sind tatsächlich ortskräfte
wenn man die familien mit rein rechnet
sind es 16,4 prozent also nicht einmal
jeder fünfte der menschen die wir da in
den gefüllten fällt man kann sagen
überfüllten flugzeugen gesehen haben
sind tatsächlich die menschen von denen
man uns gesagt hat wir müssen diese
menschen vollkommen zu recht übrigens
retten daraus leitet sich logischerweise
nicht nur eine frage ab sondern es
reihten sich gleich zwei fragen ab
erstens wer sind die menschen die jetzt
bei uns sind und zweitens was es denn
mit den anderen ort kräften geworden
haben wir da vielleicht viel mehr
menschen zurückgelassen aber ich glaube
die frage die menschen in unserem land
ganz besonders bewegt ist tatsächlich
wen haben wir denn da jetzt geholt wenn
das versprechen der regierung so klar
ein anderes war die antwort von cdu vize
thomas strobl immer ein innenminister in
baden württemberg darauf war denkbar
lapidar hätte hätte fahrradkette ich
werde also gesagt na hauptsache da war
jemand drin in den flugzeugen sinngemäß
hatte aber einfach nichts mit dem zu tun
was die bundesregierung angekündigt und
so engagiert in den letzten tagen
vertreten hat und da schließen sich
weitere fragen an die besonders im
wahlkampf noch große brisant haben
werden hätte hätte fahrradkette hast du
den baden württembergischen
innenminister thomas strobl gerade
zitiert der stand nämlich vor wenigen
minuten da wo du gerade stehst und hat
genau das gesagt auf die frage ob man
nicht hätte kontrollieren können vor ort
schon in kabul nur mit seiner erfahrung
julian hältst du das für möglich wir
haben tagelang berichtet wie sich dieses
zeitfenster in kabul schließt wie
dramatisch die situation ist wie viele
tausende menschen dort am flughafen
einfach nur eins wollen weg von den
taliban gewaltiger druck auf die
bundesregierung gewaltiger druck auf
entscheidungsträger hält es für möglich
auch im nachhinein zu sagen diese
sicherheits über prüfung die laut thomas
strobl 30 minuten dauert hätte man in
kabul machen müssen machen können also
ich glaube das was man immer wieder ganz
klar sagen muss ist dass dieser prozess
vor monaten schon verkorkst worden ist
all das was menschen in diesem land
vollkommen zu recht erwarten nämlich
dass wir wissen wer zu uns kommt die
flüchtlingskrise von 2015 ist da ist
nicht das hauptproblem dass es
flüchtlinge gab da ist das hauptproblem
das wir nie wussten wer da zu uns
gekommen ist das größte problem der
flüchtlingskrise war wer ist da zu uns
gekommen wir wussten es nicht das war
die eine lektion von der man auch immer
gesagt hat man würde sie lernen jetzt
hat man oft meinen prozess gewählt bei
dem man diese eine frage wer kommt da
eigentlich zu uns nicht beantwortet hat
nicht beantworten konnte und das
ergebnis ist die leute die wir hier
bringen wollten sind gar nicht hier und
wir hier ist wissen wir nicht so genau
das hätte man natürlich anders lösen
können wenn man sich früher darum
gekümmert hat wir haben alle die
herzzerreißenden bilder am flughafen von
kabul gesehen wenn da erstmal die
menschen gegen diese mauern ja brannten
muss man tatsächlich sagen dann ist es
natürlich unmöglich da noch wirklich zu
überprüfen wer steigt denn da jetzt in
das flugzeug aber dass dieser einsatz
endet wusste man ja dass wir dieser ort
kräfte rausholen wollen wusste man ja
dass wir jetzt zu so einem hohen anteil
menschen wieder in dieses land tun von
dem wir nicht wissen wer sie sind ist
kein automatismus sondern das ist das
ergebnis davon dass man sich nicht darum
gekümmert hat das heißt die lehre und
das versprechen was man uns nach der
flüchtlingskrise gegeben hat wir kümmern
uns darum dass das nicht noch mal
passiert das ist einfach ganz klar nicht
eingehalten worden und da ist hätte
hätte fahrradkette muss ich sagen eine
antwort die für mich ganz viel ausdrückt
weil es zeigt ein bisschen diese
sichtweise auf uns ja dass unser
bedürfnis nach sicherheit danach zu
wissen wer in dieses land kommt offenbar
selbst innenminister selbst
innenminister wird sie entlang ich es
war in dem moment zweitrangig sagt
thomas strohe hier es ging um hilfe es
ging humanitäre und einer recht hierfür
ganz klar sagen wir wollen helfen aber
wir haben als land
vollkommen zu recht sehr konkrete
vorstellungen davon wem wir helfen
wollen wir wollen nicht einfach
irgendwem helfen sondern es gab hier
eine ganz klare mission für diese ganz
klare mission haben wir menschenleben
riskiert leben von deutschen soldaten
riskiert und man muss einfach sagen
diese mission ist offenkundig nicht
erfüllt worden und die regierung sollte
uns jetzt schleunigst sagen warum das
nicht erfüllt worden ist anstatt zu
sagen hätte hätte fahrradkette und
hauptsache irgendwer war im flugzeug
gestern beim trail da war das überhaupt
gar kein thema in dieser tiefe wie wir
das jetzt hier diskutieren warum ja das
frage ich mich auch ein bisschen und da
wird es natürlich dann auch über brisant
und brenzlig wir haben in den letzten
jahren ihr durchaus einen zusammenhang
zwischen zuwanderung ohne zu wissen wer
da kommt und dem thema kriminalität
gesehen das hat es ganz eindeutig
gegeben und das ist natürlich das ganz
brisante thema daran die menschen haben
mir nicht angst davor dass irgendwer
kommt sondern dass kriminelle kommen
wenn wir nicht wissen wer da eigentlich
kommt oder menschen die in deutschland
kriminell werden und was mich gestern
beim dreh mit annalena baerbock armin
laschet und olaf scholz tatsächlich
extrem verwundert hat ist das das wort
migration überhaupt nicht gefallen ist
aber das was das thema ist was zu viele
menschen daraus umtreibt nämlich
migration und kriminalität schon gar
nicht angesprochen wurde gab einen
bemerkenswerten moment da wurden die
drei kandidaten gefragt was schätzen sie
wo frauen am meisten angst haben und die
haben dann gesagt ja also vermutlich
bushaltestellen oder unterführungen und
dann haben die moderatoren gesagt ja das
kommt so ungefähr hin es wurde aber gar
nicht gesagt warum denn frauen an
bushaltestellen oder haltestellen oder
unterführungen oder nachts im park angst
haben die haben wenn die angst vorm park
die haben auch nicht angst vor der
haltestelle dem auch nicht angst vor der
unterführung die unterführung ist noch
nie über eine frau hergefallen sondern
das waren dann meistens menschen in
diesen unterführung und da muss man
leider ganz klar sagen ich habe mir die
zahlen heute einfach noch einmal
angeschaut in der polizeilichen
kriminalitätsstatistik
2020 in deutschland
8000 4 100 tatverdächtige
und da von
3100 nichtdeutsche tatverdächtige das
ist leider muss man sagen ein enorm
hoher anteil dafür dass wir ungefähr 10
11 12 prozent nicht deutsche überhaupt
nicht deutsche staatsbürger in diesem
land haben wir sind bei 30 40 teilweise
nahe an 50 prozent beteiligung
gewaltkriminalität und das ist natürlich
ein thema was menschen umtreibt was
menschen sorgen macht was natürlich was
mit migration zu tun hat und dass das
nicht angesprochen wird sondern dass so
getan wird als wird die bushaltestelle
schuld dass frauen sich unwohl fühlen
und dieses thema vollkommen
ausgeklammert wird das halte ich im
wahlkampf für gefährlich bei menschen
immer das gefühl haben da wird ein thema
verschwiegen was mir wichtig ist was
mich betrifft was mir angst macht was
mir sorgen macht worauf ich antworten
haben möchte und wenn ich diese
antworten eben nicht bei den kandidaten
der mitte bekommen dann suche ich sie
mir woanders und das ist der trend den
wir lebten und leider geht es in diesem
wahlkampf schon wieder in diese richtung
in diesem zusammenhang migration und
kriminalität müssen wir auch über
sogenannte ehrenmorde sprechen und
möchte einmal noch mal zu hause zeigen
ein tief unserer kollegin jude cebin
spart sie hat genau das nämlich gestern
geschrieben ehrenmorde im extrem
konservativen islam an sozusagen und
keuschen familienmitgliedern häufig
frauen werden verübt um die ehre der
familie wiederherzustellen wird diesen
fakt unter rassismus verdacht stellt ihn
von dem kulturellen hintergrund loslöst
der verhindert auch gegenmaßnahmen also
aber mit meinen worten übersetzt die
zahl der ehrenmorde hier unter uns
christen deutschen ist vergleichsweise
gering
dem was unsere kollegin der getwittert
hat ging ja einen sozusagen um
erziehungs versuch aus dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen fernsehen hervor
wo glaube ich das zdf quasi getwittert
hat dass dieses thema ehrenmord der
ehrenmord sozial kulturell zuordnet dass
das eine rassistische komponente habe
ich weiß nicht ob wir das noch einmal
zeigen können hoch interessant und ich
glaube das ist etwas was da auch ein
bisschen mit reinspielt dieses thema wir
berichten medien darüber wir berichten
darüber so wie es die zahlen zeigen und
so wie wir es mit unseren reportern
sehen es gibt aber durchaus inzwischen
eine art und weise darüber zu berichten
wo das was offenkundig ist
geleugnet und abgestritten wird und die
menschen quasi umerzogen werden wollen
nicht mehr zu glauben dass der ehrenmord
etwas mit religiösen oder kulturellen
hintergrund zu tun hat und natürlich hat
er das und natürlich wenn wir über die
den ehrenmord der letzten wochen der
über den groß berichtet wurde sprechen
dann ist das ist er verübt worden von
menschen die aus afghanistan zu uns
gekommen sind um schutz zu suchen da
wandert ein phänomen zunehmend zu uns
ein das furchtbar ist das abscheulich
ist das religiös und kulturell motiviert
ist und das wird das muss man einmal
ganz klar sagen hier in deutschland
nicht haben wollen es ist nicht so dass
wir sonst keine kriminalität hätten
natürlich hätten wir die wir wollen nur
nicht dass diese phänomene zu uns
einwandern und das dann in medien so
getan wird als hätten diese phänomene
mit dem religiösen und kulturellen
hintergrund nichts zu tun und er
tatsächlich stadtinformation umerziehung
betrieben werden soll das halte ich
persönlich für hochgefährlich
[Musik]